I give talks to kids or public audiences
and I show them a picture of what it
looks like when you stain microbes
and what we see under the microscope and
inevitably the first thing people say is
in you and that's not the reaction you
should be having you should be clapping
and standing up and saying thank
goodness those microbes are in the water
because who knows where we would be
without them microbes are water keeping
the oceans healthy and if we want to
understand the ocean we have to
understand microbes this can be a hard
thing to communicate to people how
important and how exciting microbes are
but really they're in charge of
everything
no organism lives on its own it always
lives in collaboration with a group of
microbes of some sort or another and so
any phenomenon that we want to study we
really need to know what the microbial
world is doing in that particular
context because they are at the basis of
they're the ones that produce oxygen
they are the ones that fix carbon we
tend to think of things that we can see
as being the really important
contributors to the environment and
environmental change or stasis but
microbes are much more important if we
look at the oceans that I work in for
example the microbes the stuff that you
can't see are actually about 95 percent
of the living material by weight in the
oceans is microbial so by weight not by
number and those microbes produce 50
percent of the oxygen in the planet and
they're their major drivers of global
biogeochemical cycle so if it wasn't for
the microbes in the ocean the planet
would probably be dead it's a very very
important context and and people often
don't have that perception we always
hear about microbes in a negative
context they may
you sickly make you wheel but in fact
we're completely bathed in a sea of
microbes microbes are really important
to just about every service that we
require out of the environment they help
clean the air that we breathe and keep
our oceans and lakes clean one example
of that is we rely really heavily on
sewage treatment you know we don't live
in a world where there's some smelly
waste flowing around our cities and we
have microbes to thank for that microbes
are what make a wastewater treatment
system work and those same processes are
going on in the ocean so if we didn't
have microbes in the ocean the ocean
would smell and look like a wastewater
treatment plant but it doesn't because
we have microbes that are constantly
working to clean up the ocean so we rely
really heavily on them for cleaning up
waste and keeping the waters that we
drink and recreate in clean the typical
citizen will know from the ocean the
whales the Sharks they don't matter what
matters is the invisible part of life in
ocean and we have many more experts that
study sparrows then all combined that
studied marine protests but marine
protists produce half of world's oxygen
and you can count people who really
understand them on fingers of your both
hands so this is tragically overlooked
part of living organisms on this planet
because they are not fancy they are
difficult to study if you want to study
something that is 100 meters deep
somewhere in the ocean it's tough but it
matters to the well-being of this planet
much more than actually the sparrow or
whale or dolphin we're never alone
I mean microbes there they're everywhere
they're there you know they're in our
guts right now they're on our skin
they're in our noses they're in our
mouths they're on our teeth they're
everywhere and that's that's sort of an
easy answer but the important thing is
that they're everywhere and they're
doing important
if microbial life stopped now we die if
we all die microbial life would go on
essentially unchanged so they drive the
the geochemical biogeochemical cycles on
the planet
they allow us to be they allow us to
digest our food they allow insects to
eat trees they they're everywhere
they do they are the most important
organisms on the planet and we really
don't know how they work and so that you
know to me it's it's it's I mean there's
lots of big mysteries in science the
ocean space but a lot of those
especially the ocean it's a microbial
environment and we need to understand
how it works
[Music]
microbes form this huge network and one
thing that we've really come to
understand over the last few years is
just how diverse and how many different
kinds of microbes there are in any given
type of environment so I think the big
question is understanding how these
microbes fit together to form a network
that result in some emergent property of
an ecosystem so you have 10,000
different types of microbes in one
milliliter of seawater how tall those
microbes interact with one another do
they interact with one another what
happens if you remove one of them how
does that network break down I think
that's the big question now we
understand which microbes are there but
understanding how they interact with
each other are they helping each other
are they competing are they eating each
other are they fighting understanding
those interactions I think really is a
big question
[Music]
[Music]